Nhanh Cray Nga ngày 6.5, các bột ngà tiến hành các đợt tấn công tin lừa, nhằm vào hạt tấn năng lượng khắc cúp và một cơ sở về nghiệp Mỹ tại Nhi Pro.
Đông thời cho rằng mắt cứ vào đàn cố ý nhằm vào lưỡi quảng Washington.
Dới chức uc Cray Nga cho biết nha đã phong nằm tin lượng vào khắc cúp thành phố lưỡi thứ 2, cả nước.
Các đòn đánh anh gần chực tiếp đến sở ấm nước xin hoạt và đời sống dân thường.
Gây hư 2 hệ thống năng lượng giữa thời gian lạnh. Văn phòng công tổ của bực sắc nhận ít nhất một dân thường bị thường.
Tại Nhi Pro, một cuộc tấn công đã đánh chúng nhà mấy của tập đoàn đông nghiệp Mỹ là đung gờ làm giòn gì khoảng 30 tấn dầu hướng dân và buộc đón cơ tạm thời một tướng đường vèn sông.
Tất cả đung gờ cho biết, không có thương bong tại cơ sở và đăng phố hợp với chính quyền địa quyền để khắc khục sự cốm.
Mọi trường uc quan ra Andrew C. B. Hà Nội, buộc tấn công tại truyền bong không phải là nhập đánh.
Cá buộc nha nhằm mục tiêu của chủ ý vào dân nghiệp Mỹ, khoảng đó rất là các lỗ lực hoa bình dầu hoa sinh cân túc đại.
Puyên nha chưa đưa ra bình gọi về các cá cá buộc này.
Các cuộc công kích dễn ra trong bối cạnh uc quan ra và Mỹ tăng cường bình động ngoài rau.
Bởi một hồi nghỉ về uc quan ra dự kiến dễn ra tại phà rì trong khi ngà tiếp tục ra tăng tấn công hệ thống năng lượng uc quan ra từ cuối năm ngoài.